c'est un rendez vous habituel du début
de l'année l'association yvelines
environnement a lancé son concours
annuel gratuit le thème en 2021 celui
des chauves-souris tous les participants
doivent remplir une grille de mots
autour de l'animal et illustrer le thème
nos amis les chauves-souris la
présidente divine environnement présente
les objectifs du concours au micro de
justin brasilia plusieurs objectifs à ce
concours il ya un l'information du
public
l'information des structures dont je
vous ai parlé notamment l'éducation
nationale et cette nouvelle structure du
département et puis d'autre part la
connaissance d'un élément important si
vous voulez pour notre biodiversité et
troisièmement les visites de sites
particulièrement intéressant à l'aise au
niveau du département pour justement que
ceux qui ont participé soit mise en
contact avec des questions concrètes et
pour vous renseigner sur le thème vous
procure également un bulletin de
participation rendez vous sur le site
internet d'yveline environnement avant
le 7 avril et date limite de la
participation